yeah little snippet of work from home
and as a snippet what's to come for this
new era for the fifth Harmony's highly
anticipated second album is out May 20th
and the girls tell ET it's more mature
and vulnerable than reflection there's a
lot of love involved we kind of took the
time to for ourselves throughout that
past year and so we kind of incorporated
our experiences of what we've gone
through heartbreak through love
everything that is everything and I
think the sound white we were very into
the project this time where we can
change it into like what we wanted talk
about your guys's involvement lyrically
because I did see that that was
important to you to write more yeah
totally we have an amazing relationship
with the songwriters and the producers
if we want to incorporate a message
within a song mm-hmm they're right there
and they completely just know how to
translate it for us and I feel like we
just want to be more authentic yeah it's
more personal to us they definitely
write and leave the records with us
and our personalities in mind which is
cool I saw that you guys were working
with Jack Antonoff
and also Max Martin yeah well max is
Max's camp MXM uh-huh so yeah I needed
two songs they did yes mm that made it
to the album both protected thank you
yeah two from every time just camp two
minutes are those there upbeat tracks
are they all kind of feeding on trust as
we want to reveal so much about the
album but we also want to keep it a
surprise okay so the album's are
completely done though
oh you have albums done okay and I
really want to talk about the cover art
7:27 that's the day that you guys formed
on x-factor we make sure we make sure we
make sure we had Matt say about this
picture for some reason just resonated
so intensely for all of us it's such a
classic look we were super super set on
it album aside the girls are also giving
back on Monday they spent the day
talking with at-risk youth through urban
Fitness nine-one-one we saw a bit of
ourselves within these kids letting
we've been in the situations that they
have been in before so we just feel like
it was our duty and like our mission to
kind of encourage them you know that
there was a way out and that there is
hope and as long as they have faith